bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo analyse dédié au trailer
de thor sortis dans la nuit de lundi
j'arrive après tout le monde j'en suis
sincèrement désolé ma vie personnelle
prend beaucoup de place en ce moment
donc voilà on va se rattraper en juin
comptait sur moi il ya plein de vidéos à
sortir je vous ai pas oubliés en
attendant bas aujourd'hui je vais vous
proposer ma vision des choses concernant
ce trailer voir ce que nous pouvons en
tirer enfin nous voyons gore d'ailleurs
ça ça fait plaisir et caetera et puis
bah voilà juste let's go en fait
analysons tout ça bon bien évidemment on
retrouve tout le délire de la praye
endgame nous n'avons toujours pas de
nouvelles de thor depuis la mort de
thanos et la fin des avengers et le film
va nous dédier le début pour répondre à
tous a certainement je vous invite à
voir l'analyse du teaser que nous avions
fait en complément histoire d'avoir
toutes les infos ce qui est intéressant
dans ce trailer c'est bien évidemment le
cas de gore il y à aussi il arrivait de
jane en tant que mighty thor et il ya
quand même des détails que je trouve
intriguant personnellement bon
commençons par gore le design de gore je
le trouve ok perso christian bale fait
bien flipper maquillé comme ça on
reconnaît gore quand même certains codes
du personnage sont là mais voilà en vrai
c'est secondaire - ce qui va m'importe
est le plus c'est si marvel va bien
respecté l'antagoniste son histoire et
sa puissance car oui même s'il ya
toujours une certaine arts et écritures
et il y aura de la réécriture pour gore
et bien il ya quand même plein de choses
à respecter et à retranscrire à l'écran
gore et l'un si ce n'est le plus grand
ennemi de thor dans les comics c'est un
personnage qui a marqué les lecteurs
alors que pourtant il est très récent
2013 sa première apparition et ce n'est
pas par hasard gore est un antagoniste
unique et monstrueusement puissant et
j'espère vraiment que l'on va le
ressentir
si nous essayons de lier ce qui
symbolise gore dans les comics par
rapport au trailer il ya peut-être moyen
de déduire certaines choses pour rappel
et pour celles et ceux qui ne le savent
pas gore est à l'origine un être annales
sans pouvoir et sans histoire il n'est
qu'un simple extraterrestre issue d'une
race inconnue et provenant d'une planète
qui n'a même pas de nom très pieux il
dévoue son existence pour les prières et
sa croyance envers les dieux la planète
de gore est très hostile et avare de
ressources donc voilà les prières
servent de réconfort et d'espoir pour le
peuple sauf que les dieux
n'interviennent jamais et au fil du
temps à cause de la dangerosité de
l'environnement de la planète gore va
perdre toute sa famille il va remettre
en question sa foi et cela le poussera à
l'exil sauf que pendant son bannissement
il sera témoin d'une confrontation entre
deux divinités majeur lui faisant
prendre conscience que les dieu existe
très amer d'être témoin que les dieux
existe véritablement et qu'en plus ils
n'ont jamais écouté ses prières gore va
se lier à all blacks donnés crossword
larmes symbiote du dieu neil blessés au
combat et partira dans une quête ultime
qui est de se venger de tous les dieux
bon voilà j'essaye de résumer au maximum
et que ce soit pas trop long par rapport
au trailer il semblerait que le délire
de symbiote va passer à la trappe et
franchement cela ne m'étonne pas
vraiment étant donné que sony pictures
possède spider man venom et donc par
extension bas tout ce qui est relié au
délire et au concept de symbiote et bien
cela voudrait dire que si ils
retranscrivent véritablement ce qu'il ya
dans les comics il faudrait du coût lié
sony pictures au projet et je pense pas
que ce soit vraiment quelque chose de
convoiter du coup voilà c'est déjà une
première réécriture après peut-être que
j'ai tort un peut-être que marvel a le
droit d'utiliser
le concept de symbiote et cetera sans
avoir sony dans les pattes mais bon
ensuite il ne faut pas oublier que dans
le même c'est une all blacks se
nécrosent world a été réécrit pour être
larmes dès la cette dernière peut
invoquer des armes par le biais de son
casque donc pareil gore ne semble pas
avoir récupéré l'équipe mandela donc
cela sera sans doute réécrit néanmoins
même sens tout cela le trailer semble
respectée en partie des éléments de la
puissance de gore par exemple le moment
où jane fait la rencontre de tort nous
voyons que thor est en train de se
battre avec d'autres personnes contre
des créatures un peu étrange je pense
très sincèrement que c'est l'oeuvre de
gore car dans les comics all blacks
donnés crossword confère le pouvoir à
gore de matérialiser n'importe quelle
arme pour se battre dû à sa condition de
symbiote et il peut également se crée
une sorte d'armé d'ailleurs au moment où
nous voyons gore apparaître il est dans
un endroit qui rappelle le design des
créatures et cet endroit semble être une
manifestation des pouvoirs de gore donc
voilà les créatures pourrait donc être
un signe de l'arrivée de gore un moyen
d'attaquer les dieux un peu partout à
travers l'espace avant d'intervenir lui
même ensuite ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est le cas de l'épée de
gore le trailer nous fait un gros focus
dessus pour bien nous informer qu'elle
est importante et qu'elle semble être la
source des pouvoirs de gore c'est comme
pour all blacks donnés crossword en soi
est d'ailleurs éléments qu'il faut
souligner nos voyons gore à un moment
donné créer une sorte d' onde de choc
sur une lune par le biais de son épée
c'est un élément important pour moi car
par rapport aux comics all blacks donnés
crossword permettent à gordes absorber
et assimilés les pouvoirs de ses
victimes normalement c'est grâce au
concept de symbiote avec leur mémoire
génétique mais bref du coup ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que cela semble
être également le cas dans le mc eu
puisque déjà nous faisons face à une
évolution de l'antagoniste nous voyons
gore to clean puis à un certain moment
nous le voyons de manière horrifique
comme si il déborde de puissance et par
rapport à l'ombre de choc sur la lune
gore semble pouvoir manipuler
l'électricité si on suit la logique
cela voudrait dire qu'il a volé ce
pouvoir un dieu bon je ne pense pas que
ce soit or ni jane mais peut-être que ce
serait du ce pourquoi pas nous verrons
bien bon en tout cas je suis plutôt
confiant pour le moment concernant gore
les films de torts sont d'ailleurs
réputés pour leurs couleurs très vives
depuis tort ragnarok là à voir que gore
et comme un antagoniste qui absorbent la
lumière et qui amène la sombre heures et
bien j'aime bien cette idée maintenant
nous pouvons parler de l'arrivée de jane
car il ya un détail que je trouve très
intéressant à relever c'est le fait que
thor n'ai jamais récupéré mjolnir bon
après ça peut être une manipulation des
traileurs un tout reste possible le fait
que thor est abandonnée mjolnir après sa
destruction dans thor ragnarok est
plutôt intéressante car cela ferait écho
à l'origine story de jane en tant que
mighty thor dans les comics en gros je
vous l'avais expliqué mes torts à un
moment donné ne sera plus digne de
porter mjolnir et du coup tort devra
abandonner son arme sur la lune le
marteau va finalement se réveiller et
appellera jane alors victime de son
cancer qui est l'emploi n'y aura pour
devenir la mighty thor là dans le
trailer on semble avoir le même délire
que dans les comics jane serait en
possession de mieux venir tandis que
thor serait passé à autre chose après
cela soulève quand même certaines
questions comment mjolnir serré
assemblée cela peut être complètement
bête du style juste le marteau s'est
reformé au contact de jane ou bien
peut-être que c'est l'oeuvre de
quelqu'un et puis pareil pourquoi tout à
coup de jane empoigne mjolnir je suis
curieux de voir ce qui est prévu la
concernant pour le mc peut-être que jane
a été appelé par mjolnir et en est
devenu digne carte or est en danger odin
avait peut-être prévu que jane empoigne
mieux tout est possible en vrai comme
explication pour le moment d'ailleurs
détail qui peut être pertinent c'est que
jen aurait possiblement été snap et par
thanos elle aurait disparu pendant cinq
ans étant donné que pour elle elle n'a
pas vu tort depuis environ trois ou
quatre ans alors que c'est bien plus
pour thor ce qui expliquerait aussi
pourquoi elle ne portait pas mjolnir
avant mais bon c'est une idée comme ça
on a trop peu d'infos enfin il faut que
nous terminions sur un détail de fou
apparu dans le trailer c'est la première
chose que j'ai remarqué quand je les ai
vus et j'en ai même fait la mention sur
twitter tellement c'est un détail que je
trouve pas trop bien quoi depuis le
début de la phase 4 le mc eu à vence
considérablement il ya énormément de
petites références de petits easter egg
qui ont une importance gigantesque et
qui permet en gros de
légitimer plein de choses par rapport au
film comme dans les comics quoi par
exemple le tribunal vivent on en parle
très souvent un il est apparu du court
comme petites références dans doctor
strange un il est réapparu dans doctor
strange 2 il y a aussi la présence de la
tête de statue dans l'eau qui bref est
bien là encore une fois il réapparaît
dans en tant que ce statut dans thor 4
love and thunder est en vrai c'est le
genre de détail qui est trop bien là
dans le trailer nous voyons jane dans
une sorte de temple regroupant plusieurs
statues qui représente les plus grandes
entités de marvel les personnages les
plus puissants des dieux pour les dieux
eux mêmes nous voyons donc le tribunal
vivent comme je disais il y a aussi le
watchers nous avons la présence de la
mort elle même entité dont anne hausse
est amoureux dans les comics à la base
nous voyons aussi et hommes et infiniti
si ce sont bel et bien eu et la dernière
statue on ne la voit pas trop mais bref
tous ces êtres sont des êtres ultra
cosmique des entités au dessus de tout
dans l'univers marvel et comme d'hab
c'est peut-être idiot et anodin pour
certains mais amener ne serait-ce qu'une
statue de ces entités et bien cela
permet de les légitimé pour l'univers du
mc eu nous prouver qu'ils existent et
que possiblement ils apparaîtront un
jour après tout on a déjà eu le watchers
dans what if le tribunal vivent a été
référencé beaucoup de fois donc perso je
pense que nous le verrons très
prochainement et puis je ne sais pas
mais ça se trouve nous aurons peut-être
l'intervention de l'une de ces entités
directement dans thor 4 gore est en
quête de la destruction de tous les
dieux cela veut dire qu'il convoite
aussi la mort de ces entités donc nous
aurons peut-être une surprise perso
j'attends le tribunal vivent depuis
longtemps mais bon je ne me crée pas de
faux espoirs non plus
écoutez je n'ai pas grand chose de plus
à dire concernant le trailer on avait
déjà pas mal parlé de thor 4 par le
biais du teaser donc je vous conseille
vraiment de voir cette vidéo en
complément de celle ci tiens si je vais
oublier mon peut mentionner par exemple
le tatouage de thor dans le trailer qui
fait référence du coup à loki qui est
mort bas dans une finity voir face à la
noce ce serait vraiment cool qu'un jour
le lot qui a survécu dans le tva
rencontre tort ce serait ce serait
quelque chose de marrant mais ça
arrivera certainement un jour en
attendant j'espère que la vidéo vous
aura plu c'était une analyse très humble
en vrai il y a même si le trailer est
très cool je voyais pas trop quoi dire
de plus à part
gore jane et puis bah le coût des
statuts il ya beaucoup de plans qui ont
été repris du teaser bien évidemment et
puis voilà cela reste un trailer mais en
tout cas c'est vraiment cool d'enfin
voir gore et voir de nouvelles images
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleus si la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à laisser un petit commentaire et
surtout à vous abonner à la chaîne pour
ne pas louper les prochaines vidéos on
se retrouve très vite j'ai plein de
vidéos à vous faire notamment sur doctor
strange de et puis bah écoute et que le
lionheart soit avec vous cet argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]